apparently this place is very chic my
fiance says they make great dirt welcome
to sofi i'm sure you've all been to
restaurants but we do things a little
different
um yeah i moved to the la section of
gridiron heights to chase my dreams oh
good for you who was this person anyway
the menu is up on the giant screen thank
you but we all brought our own weird
food oh they must be in town for the mvp
regatta we should compete no i don't
deserve good things we talked about that
war daddy who's the reason the rams are
doing so well i am
let the mvp race begin
but everything was great so recently
this thing honestly drives itself at
this point all right brady's in the lead
but you got this sorry for beating you
tom i don't know who i think i am yo
what up i'm mad from the watch
oh man he's unfortunately a delight wait
rogers is doing it all himself i don't
trust traditional propellants i prefer
homeopathic methods like pure spite you
hear that wind you don't blow me i
blow you do you have a life jacket yeah
i'm immunized to drowning do you have a
life jacket i don't judge anyone who has
a life
it's not too late for mr unlimited just
enjoy the lose cruise russ we're all
rooting for coach gable to finally win
we tied
but with heart
[Music]
what the hell these dolphins came out of
nowhere
to fly party margins
damn i
oh now it's we there's too many people
guys i'm telling you stand up
paddleboard yoga it shreds your core oh
geez my homes again look media
golly it's a 17 game monsoon too many
things can go wrong in there you gotta
cut me lose no we can both win mvp like
steve mcnair and peyton and 03.
receivers can't win anyway you got to
cut me out of the narrative
oh no the titans wow a mermaid
oh whoops oh hey trevor i can't do it i
gotta rest yeah colors out peace never
mind i guess i'm back in the storm i'm
matt stafford and i am the storm
when did the bay area get so rocky
[Music]
uh can someone come get me
oh there's coach hey
wait why is he going over to odell
beckham oh no
oh oh hey don't forget me coach wait
who's that oh god clammy's back my
gritty little babies and that was
gridiron heights weekly through the
super bowl clean the [ __ ] up